the founder of one of the world's
biggest cryptocurrency exchanges has
been charged with defrauding investors
out of 1.8 billion dollars so who is Sam
bankman freed and what went wrong
Sam bankman freed universally known as
SBF as perhaps the highest profile boss
in crypto his exchange FTX allowed
investors around a million of them at
the time it collapsed to trade real
money dollars pounds whatever it may be
for cryptocurrencies which were then
traded and exchanged on the platform at
the same time he was running another
business Allah Madea research was a
which was a crypto hedge fund taking
high risk bets using money that should
have been separate from ftx's customer
money now this business grew really fast
that's not least to celebrity
endorsements he paid a great deal of
money to get the likes of Gisele and the
U.S football legend Tom Brady to endorse
the platform Larry David the comedian
they brought glamor and he got gravitas
from inviting former presidents and
prime ministers Bill Clinton and Tony
Blair famously shared a platform with
him at a glitzy conference in the
Bahamas he was lobbying in Washington
not just lobbying but throwing money at
lawmakers a huge amount of political
donations coming from fdx's apparent
fortunes that put his personal wealth at
one point valued at more than 20 billion
dollars
a few weeks ago things went badly wrong
there were questions about where Alameda
research was getting its money the value
of fdx's own native coin ftt started to
crumble and fall and with those
questions investors tried to withdraw
their funds there was a run on ftx's
people scrambled to withdraw billions of
dollars they couldn't get their hands on
the money because it lacked the
liquidity and the exchange was frozen
there's an estimate of between eight and
ten billion dollars of customer money
locked into that platform and now the
authorities the Securities and Exchange
Commission and federal prosecutors are
alleging that in fact what was happening
was SPF was taking customer money that's
the money ordinary investors like you
and I would have put in and shoveling it
through a back door into his hedge fund
business you can't do that and not
expect to face investigation by the
authorities and they say this is this
might be a brand new kind of trading a
brand new digital currency but it's a
very old form of financial crime fraud
small group of grossly inexperienced an
unsophisticated individuals
failed to implement virtually any of the
systems or controlled that are necessary
for a company entrusted with other
people's money or assets
question for small investors who've been
in crypto for the last year or two is
whether they'll recover the losses if
you've got your money in FTX that is a
very moot point but we've seen Bitcoin
the value of the most established and
largest cryptocurrency plunge from over
sixty thousand dollars to a little over
sixteen thousand dollars this year
those who believe will say it's just a
dip in the roller coaster of crypto and
it will come back plenty who wonder if
smaller investors will ever see their
money again